what I first want us to investigate is
that original graph that we're just
looking at right so we said I'm just
gonna zoom back up we said painted this
times time equals 48 and I put painters
on the horizontal axis that's kind of
like our X and I put time on the
vertical axis that's kind of like our Y
right so what I'd love you to write in
your equation is x times y equals 48 now
you may need to zoom out a little bit to
actually see what's going on but you
shouldn't have a shape someone that
looks like that right so you can
recognize that same hyperbola that we
just drew just by hand right business
shape there you can see as painters
increases time decreases okay you can
even see some of the values that we
thought about they're actually on this
graph so for example I don't know do you
guys know how to put coordinates on
today's was have you done this before
yeah so for example if you go over here
bottom left hand corner right opens
brackets okay
we said six painters that was the
question wasn't it
six painters that's the x value if you
put in a comma it should give you how
much time how many hours did we say what
was that answer yeah it was eight wasn't
it
six painters eight days okay and there
you go you can see that point is on the
graph in fact if you zoom to the right
level you can actually see the
coordinate axes right you can put
another one what was the another one we
tried I think we said things like what
was that if you had just you and a
friend to comma how many days would take
you 24 thank you very much 24 now that's
got all the way up but if you pinch out
you can see there it is right there
okay so there's a solution but there is
one important difference between the
graph that we drew and this graph what's
extra what's additional on here that we
didn't have yeah very good so you can
see when we just pop this in two days
once you got like extra stuff over here
right now why do you think I
deliberately asked you not to draw this
part of the plane when we were doing it
by hand why did I ask you to not include
that there's a sensible reason why I
think about it yeah
okay so number one this guy over here is
actually a mirror image if you take your
computer which I cannot do to this
projector and you just kind of rotate at
45 degrees like if you look at it like
that okay you can see this is a
reflection across in fact I'll even put
the reflection line on so that you can
see it this is what it looks like and
more equals minus if I could type
properly with my stubby fingers that
would help
hey yeah there's the line of symmetry so
that's great so it's like look this guy
is going to be exactly the same as that
guy same shape just the other side okay
but it's a more important reason right
we explored one painter to paint it's
three painters 2,000 pages you know what
you can't have negative painters all
right unless there's like a guy like
stripping paint off while you paint what
a jerk okay so this situation over here
doesn't make sense or isn't relevant for
the particular example we looked at but
what we're going to now do is consider
when it is so from now on and underneath
where you drew that original graph
underneath when you drew that one I love
you to draw a new Cartesian plane and
this time we are going to need the whole
thing you definitely do draw this with a
ruler okay so let's have a look at one a
together they're going to ask us for a
bunch of things right so question one
the first thing they asked for in part a
is can someone tell me what's the piece
of information they're after say that
again
domain your age thank you so I'm just
gonna write D and and it's nice and
simple for Part B I think they asked for
and didn't ask for an intercept yet
y-intercept if there is one why is that
what are they asking for in Part C
sketch okay so that's four things in
total domain range y-intercept and then
we are going to get a drawing out okay
and then the very first thing that they
give us is why of course I think it's
two on X isn't it to an X okay now just
before we launch into this do you notice
that this is really just dressed up in
slightly different clothes what we're
looking at with painters in time right
do you notice I could rewrite this in
this form t I could divide both sides
through by P by the number of pages you
get this
do you see that that's the Y that's the
X same deal here right so whenever
you're seeing this thing with that X on
the Nuria this is the shape you ought to
expect okay now when it comes to domain
and range
what is domain mean what is the meaning
of to making anyone throw like a phrase
or sentence at me someone has never met
domain before and you have to say well
domain is this what you say I guess it
has to do with X it's not quite the
intercepts that we will come to
intercepts in a second what how else can
we describe it ah okay there's a lot of
language in there right so I'm gonna
fasten a few ideas in it its X values
right
this thing here this graph it exists for
a whole bunch of X values I should point
out it doesn't exist for all of them
we're gonna explain explore that in a
second but it exists for a whole bunch
and domain is asking the question which
one's right where does it exist so let's
think about domain first the easiest way
to find domain is to think about
actually the opposite of that right
where does it not exist there's a single
value of x that you're not allowed to
put in this otherwise it explodes in
your face and your calculator will tell
you this 2/0 it's not nice right your
calculator will tell you what it'll say
math errors say forget it don't ask me
to do this rubbish right so X is not
allowed to equal zero but that's not
actually the domain right remember we
said before domain is where the function
does exist not the places wherever it
doesn't exist so you got a couple of
ways to say this just to keep things
simple I'm gonna give you one it's
probably the simplest way I'm gonna say
X it can be left of zero that's okay
that's not equal to zero or it can be
bigger than zero yeah so so long as
you're to the left or to the right well
you're not exactly on there this is
where you are allowed to go so that's
the way we state domain you following
with me okay that's all right
that's it . let's think about range now
range
now this is kind of the same thing range
is not about where the exercise can go
it's about where the y-values can go
okay so this is about up and down not
left and Rome now you've already got in
your page and I don't so I'm going to
quickly draw it you've already gone on
your page a complete Cartesian plane and
this was the shape that we got when you
put in this into desmos you remember
that okay so I want you to notice this
vertical asymptote which we didn't draw
before it's a reflection of you're not
allowed to go to zero x equals zero
right but there's also a spot that we're
not allowed to go vertically do you see
where it is where's that one spot you're
not allowed to go in the middle it's
kind of in the center here right it was
this very first horizontal asymptote
that we drew now just like this vertical
asymptote has an equation x equals zero
the horizontal one also has an equation
it's a horizontal line so what form will
its equation be in any takers
hmm yeah what do I can y equals zero is
an excellent guess even if you didn't
know think about this right the y axis
it has an equation x equals zero let me
say that again Y axis x equals zero so
therefore it stands to reason if you
switch everything around the x axis has
an equation y equals zero now we
established right no matter how many
painters you throw at this thing you'll
never actually get to zero did you
notice that
so therefore over here in the range I'm
gonna say well why is not allowed to be
zero but we already established that's
not telling you the answer is it that's
telling you the opposite all the XS so
can someone suggest to me what's a way I
could actually write
yeah I'm gonna follow exactly the same
pattern that I had before right these
are the parts where Y is allowed to
exist you can put those Y values in so
you look these are all the ones
underneath zero there okay these are all
the ones above zero there also okay
domain and range we're sorted okay this
is Part A let's have a look at puppet
what are they asking us for again it's a
winder set that they want if there is
one and that's actually very important
because how would we find a y-intercept
like I gave you this guy right at the
beginning right I gave you this was it a
three I think it was mmm right yeah yeah
that's right
and then you told me oh I can factorize
this right so how would you find the
y-intercept on this thing I actually
told you right at the beginning if you
can remember 17 minutes ago what would
you do
it's the negative ten because all you
have to do number one it's the constant
part but all you have to do to find the
winder set any time is to let X equal
and remember zero very good if X was
zero that's gonna become zero that's
going to become zero and that is exactly
why we get left with the constant okay
now have a look over here I'm just gonna
try it let X equal zero
does anyone see why we're gonna run into
some trouble like I literally wrote it
like four lines ago right yeah I can't
divide by zero this is the thing I
established right if I let X equal zero
there's no solution so there's no
solution that means there's no y
intercept okay which when you have a
look at the graph you're like oh of
course there's no y intercept look it
never actually touches that's what
intercepts means okay right now the last
thing is sketch now I've actually
already done most of the sketch and if
you in true your previous one if you
drew what you got out of desmos you also
have done your sketch but it's one
little difference you've still got
desmos there can you like alt-tab to it
go back to desmos do you still have this
graph on there
you haven't deleted it yep all you
next line I actually want you to put in
this just make it a new equation so
you'll see both of them at the same time
what do you get you got it this is what
I'm getting okay can we get show here
does that match with what you've got
yeah okay thank you his it sir and be
confused right because I want you to
look carefully just look up for a second
this is um this is what happened with my
painters remember that just look at that
shape really closely okay now I'm gonna
get rid of the painters and then I put
the graph we're looking at right now
this guy here now I know it looks
different they sure look different don't
they but watch this
doesn't that look exactly the same
I've just had to go in further okay so
in fact every hyperbola just looks like
all the rest of them just some are
bigger and some are smaller so if
someone gave you these two graphs and
said one of them is this and what is
that how are we going to be able to tell